we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we have this
regular caller troy york he calls in
with all sorts of different characters
he has one guy who's like his black
character i forget the guys name it's
like Malcolm Jenkins from university
something or other absolutely disastrous
impression of a black guy that he does
he has a Hispanic character named Luis
Martinez there's something like that I
don't remember what that guy's name is
anyway this is such an abortion of a
voicemail from Troy York because he's
calling in to make some kind of a
conservative political point again with
one of his fake names but we can't even
figure out what's going on because it
there's so such background noise he's
having trouble getting through the son
he's having trouble getting through
sentences it was a really sad day for
Troy York's fake voicemails let's take a
listen to it is big news for even
bringing that up just wanting to mention
Trump's name with the name of her okay
cut it I can't do it I can't do it so
this character's name was Bradley Austin
and I guess what he's upset with is that
I mentioned Trump's name during the
Holocaust denying story yeah well maybe
the character was the one who is
inarticulate yeah Troy York was playing
an inner tick youlet collar Bradley
haast this is what we're dealing with
day to day 24/7 folks 24/7 it's the
world of the production of independent
media and it is exciting and a new every
single day a Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is facing backlash over
his people kind to comment we'll talk
about that on today's bonus show there's
also a high-end London restaurant which
is launching uber style
I sing which is I guess another way to
call it as demand based pricing dynamic
pricing dynamic pricing would be another
way sort of like Airlines kind of do the
same thing and downtown Los Angeles
California parking meters will now
accept donations for a homeless outreach
program you can put extra money when you
pay for your parking in and it will be
used to help the homeless kind of
interesting because sometimes when
you're putting money into a meter you
see homeless people that are panhandling
or living on the street or whatever so
you might be emotionally primed to make
a contribution in this way so I think
that there's there's a lot to that how
do you get the bonus show anyway two
ways you become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership or you
become a patron for at least five bucks
a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we'll speak to you then